Hubsan X4 H502E Desire 2-3-18
but uh the judges would probably notice that and you can see my bow legs here so they're not
completely touching at the knees for the shins
uh that chunbi was pretty bad the fingers were all
way too straight and i realized that before while i was doing it
yeah i didn't i didn't realize that while i was doing it but the i tried to focus before
um actually doing the performance that uh that my back stance would be a lot lower and more weight
on the back leg but it did not turn out that way i guess i forgot about that while i was actually
doing it yeah what i was mostly focusing on was the preparation for my uh double knife hand blocks
i tried to make sure that one of the hands go to the hip and i think i focused on that
too much because my stances are really bad here like my right foot is totally not facing the front
and the angle of both are pretty bad
i went too high there and i realized that my head was bopping too up and down i tried to keep it in
my in my head um this next section i felt pretty pretty in the zone i don't really have to think
about what's going on here i just tried to nail each kick but then i realized that uh
for one of the move oh wow yeah i never realized that my stance was so bad but
that was something i was trying to focus on but when i was performing i completely forgot about it
i noticed that for one of these my preparation after the block and punch was too bad
um i guess i haven't practiced the preparation that much but
this block is also too high the elbow so the fish should be at shoulder level
yeah the preparation with the arms was really bad there and that really threw me off because
i realized that i hadn't practiced this enough and i didn't remember what the
preparation for everything was supposed to be with the arms
yeah here was pretty pretty normal pretty up to standard i felt pretty good about myself
yeah i was pretty natural didn't really have to think about what will come next just maybe a big
breath for the key up i tried to make sure not to keep forgot that but i'd say the beginning
when i kept making all those mistakes i was a lot more attentive to what i was doing and trying not
to make the same mistake so that ended up in me making other mistakes i maybe wouldn't have if i
wasn't thinking about those things but at the end i was pretty
pretty in the zone and didn't really have to think about what i was doing
yeah here i was confused whether i should uh uh
first uh shot and then chatty up we just go straight to chatty up and so it looks so weird
there yeah
great
i was scoring so
i think